bon ok j'avais déjà fait une vidéo
théorie sur pokémon sonné moon mais
c'était en mai nous sommes aujourd'hui
en septembre et beaucoup de nouveautés
ont été annoncées et beaucoup de mystère
au passage donc je me devais de faire
une seconde vidéo sur pokémon soleil et
lune car il ya beaucoup à dire dessus
déjà parlant de mon ancienne vidéo
est-ce que j'ai eus bon première théorie
complètement à côté de la plaque car
nous avons réellement de nouveau jeu
face à nous ensuite la seconde théorie
c'est entre guillemets réaliser car la
synergie est traduite par les capacités
z
enfin pour finir je n'avais pas vraiment
bon car pas de nouvelle méga évolution
pas de lien avec kalos du moins pour le
moment et pas de pokémon 731 cependant
j'avais raison pour qu'ils gardent et je
suis très content car nous chercherons
les petits blob 2 1% pour reconstituer
ci garde 100% et ça c'est cool je trouve
mais passons nouvelle théorie et en
voici trois que je vous propose
parlons de la grosse nouveauté qui fait
beaucoup parler d'elle je parle
évidemment des ultras chimère vous vous
souvenez de la synergie cette énergie
qui se traduit par une fusion
eh bien je suis sûr encore une fois que
les présents mais sous la forme des
ultras chimère déjà si on suit la
définition de chimères plusieurs s'offre
à nous dont une qui nous intéresse
particulièrement
une chimère est un organisme constitué
de deux ou plus rarement de plusieurs
variétés de cellules ayant des origines
génétiques différentes
on parle bien alors d'une fusion est
bien ici c'est pareil nous ne
connaissons strictement rien des ultras
chimère on ne sait même pas si ce sont
des pokémon mais j'aimerais soulever un
point vous trouvez pas que les ultras
chimères ressemble à certains
personnages du jeu us et 0,1 à la
première ultra chimères annoncé il est
dit dans sa description que cet ultra
chimères reproduit les mouvements
gracieux d'une femme
donc nous pouvons déjà l'associer à une
femme mais ensuite si on regarde bien
son physique on voit que ce monstre
ressemble comme deux gouttes d'eau à
lily le chapeau de méduses ressemble
énormément à celui de lily et rien
qu'avec la description les mouvements
d'une jeune femme lily est jeune et
c'est d'une femme ouais nan c'est pas un
assez bon argument mais cette chimère du
ressemble énormément
d'ailleurs celle-ci nous dit dans l'un
des trailer qu'elle a intérêt le secret
un rapport avec les ultras chimère
ensuite parlons de l'ultra chimères
beauty et luttera chimères expansion ici
c'est pareil
l'ultra chimères beauty la première fois
que j'ai vu m'a tout de suite fait
penser à elle à mina président de la
fondation et r2 par la longue chevelure
et le physique
que pouvons-nous supposée des ultras
chimères serait un mélange de pokémon et
d'humains souvenez-vous de la définition
de chimères organisme constitué de deux
ou plus rarement de plusieurs variétés
de cellules ayant des origines
génétiques différentes
nous sommes clairement face à une fusion
entre deux organismes soit entre humains
et pokémon mais je pense sincèrement que
c'est ultra chimères ont un rapport avec
la synergie et qu'ils aient un rapport
avec les humains cependant je suis pas
sûr qu'il soit créé d'ailleurs
bizarrement tout c'est ultra chimères
sont humanoïdes
mais pour l'ultra chimères expansion
alors eh bien
acceptons l'hypothèse que l'ultra
shimmer beauty soit associé à yamina
beauty expansion et été annoncée en même
temps et plusieurs le remarquer sur
internet mais gladio ressemble pas mal à
elsa mina et pourrait bien être son
frère
c'est assez fréquent dans les joueurs pg
japonais il n'a qu'à regarder final
fantasy par exemple dans le khat le
méchant était en fait deux frères du
gentil je parle de cécile et gaulle buzz
réussi cela pourrait être bien possible
gladio pourrait être le frère qui a mal
tourné et el amine à celle qui a réussi
et si c'est le cas on pourrait alors
supposer que gladio pourrait revenir
chez les gentils à la fin de l'histoire
les revenons à nos ultras chimères
gladio serait donc associé à l'ultra
chimères expansion examina à l'ultra
chimères duty chacun exclusive à leurs
versions et le sucre quasiment certain
que c'est ça mais pour le pokémon de
type 0 est bien une fois de plus
pour moi il est évident type-0 a été
créé pour ressembler une ultra chimère
mais pourquoi
outre le fait de vouloir contrôler le
pokémon légendaires de la version je
pense que la team sky apprenant
l'existence des ultras chimères ont
voulu en posséder une de par la
puissance de dégagent ces créatures et
ce serait pourquoi type-0 seraient créés
on voit bien que ce pokémon est pas
naturelle il a une queue de poisson un
casque il ressemble à un chien il me
fait penser à une ultra chimères qu'elle
est un mélange de plusieurs organismes
on le voit bien sur fond physique c'est
d'ailleurs gladio qui le contrôle dont
on parlait auparavant
on pourrait supposer que gladio ignore
que nulle trace chignard est associé à
celui ci
et du coup la team sky aurait créé type
0 mais il est vrai que la team ce que
leur ressemblent à des pirates qui ne
sont pas très fin leur chef buzz mahé
d'ailleurs comme qui dirait un raté il
connaissait bien à l'âme et a mal tourné
et est chef maintenant d'une
organisation de bête et méchante qui
rackettent le vol et pillent tout
simplement ils font simplement du
vandalisme
comment aurait-il crétine 0 sans moyens
et sans scientifiques et bien voici le
retour de nicolay nicolaï était un pnj
de pokemon noir de et blanc 2 c'était un
scientifique de génie qui avait aidé la
team plasma a provoqué la fusion entre q
rennes et zekrom ou reshiram cela dépend
des de votre version
et c'est lui le génie de toute cette
opération les tice avait seulement soit
de pouvoir et n a disparu cependant
nicolas et se servait juste de la team
plasma pour faire ses recherches ni plus
ni moins après le combat contre le héros
il a compris l'amour des pokémon et a
laissé le héros intervenir sur les plus
longues
bethys nicolas et serait donc de retour
dans sun et moon et ce serait lui qui
aurait créé type-0 pour alimenter tout
ça je vous rappelle que nicolas était
passionné par la fusion que pure m pour
le provoquer avec reshiram et zekrom on
retrouve ici aussi une chimère soit la
synergie car ce fut la fusion de deux
pokémon légendaires si les ultras
chimères sont des fusions de pokémon
avec les humains il est fort probable
que nicolas et façon grand retour et
cherche à créer une mule trashy meirieu
ressemble en tout en se servant de la
team skull
après tout mais la donne et c'est bien
réapparu dans x y et rose art alors
pourquoi pas nicolas
qu'en pensez vous j'aimerais avoir vos
réactions je suis vraiment impatient que
ces jeux pokémon sorte bientôt dix ans
que je joue au pokémon et je ne me lasse
pas c'était targon et merci de m'avoir
écouté